now that you're kind of like in the
position that you're in right do you
because I don't know how the video game
works like obviously there's a lot of
people who are doing what you're doing
but like are you do you like pitch for
videos yeah sometimes or are you just
people coming to you like for example
you said that you manifested the Nicki
Minaj video coming up right
which is a big deal 100
um how did that one come up like is that
something where the label reaches out to
you yeah so it's also it's featuring
someone else as well that's why I didn't
want to mention the name right and then
um so yeah that person put me in contact
and then next you know we connected and
nowadays it's more relationships and um
I barely pitch only if it's like a
really crazy opportunity like someone
that like I really was like damn like I
can't I don't have a relationship with
that person right but for the newer
generation of artists like you know most
of them know me as in my videos so same
thing like with whiz when I was doing
whiz he just you know I reached out to
him on a DM and he hit me back and we
started you know chopping up as homies
first you did the Ice style necklace and
the badass [ __ ] right no I didn't do
my style necklace I just did a bad
accident okay the baddest [ __ ] video
is crazy yeah thank you yeah and um and
yeah so it's just like building
relationships with people you got me in
really taking your time to really
understand them pull up to the studio
listen to the music right you know try
to just connect with them first as
people and then from there like be like
all right cool when the right time and
it's organic let's make it happen and
that's what happened with Wiz